Thank you.
I have just called President Obama to congratulate him on his victory.
His supporters and his campaign also deserve congratulations.
I wish all of them well, but particularly the President, the First Lady and their daughters.
This is a time of great challenges for America...
...and I pray that the President will be successful in guiding our nation.
I want to thank Paul Ryan for all that he has done for our campaign and for our country.
Besides my wife Ann, Paul was the best choice I've ever made.
And I trust that his intellect and his hard work and his commitment to principle...
...will continue to contribute to the good of our nation.
I also want to thank Ann, the love of my life.
She would have been a wonderful First Lady.
She has been that and more to me and to our family...
...and to the many people that she has touched with her compassion and her care.
The nation, as you know, is at a critical point.
At a time like this, we can't risk partisan bickering and political posturing.
Our leaders have to reach across the aisle to do the people's work.
I believe in America.
I believe in the people of America.
And I ran for office because I'm concerned about America.
This election is over, but our principles endure.
I believe that the principles upon which this nation was founded...
...are the only sure guide to a resurgent economy and to a new greatness.
Like so many of you, Paul and I have left everything on the field.
We have given our all to this campaign.
I so wish,...
...I so wish that I had been able to fulfill your hopes to lead the country in a different direction.
But the nation chose another leader.
And so Ann and I join with you to earnestly pray for him and for this great nation.
Thank you and God bless America.
You guys are the best.
Thank you so much.